at this small depot in west london a
family business is on hold as they
collect donations to send to pakistan
it's not just a community's generosity
on show here it's also one man's
desperation
nazir ali's mother and relative survived
the flooding in sindh province but are
now dealing with the devastation he says
he had to do something to help
i'm crying actually that time awareness
that there is a problem flood is coming
my mom is crying as well that time
and
i can't do because i'm not rich i have
jokes whatever money i stand in the
state of pakistan
and there is crying people
because i can't see because
woman's got no clothes
this was all given in just one day
nazir and his children hope to fill the
whole warehouse soon
but everything will be sent by sea
because flying it out is too expensive
so the journey could take six weeks or
longer people in pakistan can't wait
that long for help
we don't know what sort of
urgent
things they need
and
if if they get money and they can get
warm food they can cook food over there
they can buy
shelters they can buy tents camps
yes money is much needed right now
charities on the ground are dealing with
the most immediate problems but they
want the international community to
pledge much more financial aid
people have been displaced from their
homes so they don't have any means of
food so we've been providing hot meals
fresh clean drinking water and hygiene
kids because the biggest issue that
we're going to see now is the waterborne
diseases like cholera
it's no wonder people in the uk would
want to help when faced with scenes like
this
but pakistan needs aid urgently and will
do for some time to come becky kotchel
sky news